basically the technology is safe as far
as we can tell what much more study is
really required I am Nick Gillespie for
Reason TV if you're like me when you
think about fracking you think about the
fracking song ended documentaries like
Gasland six states have documented over
1,000 incidents of groundwater
contamination our water was good before
they started drilling that when a tech
donna was bad now when I don't know what
to think about something related to the
environment or to technology or to
science in general I do what I always do
I turn to reasons longtime science
correspondent Ron Bailey Ron thanks for
joining us delighted to be with you what
is fracking and what is the controversy
about fracking as the technology that's
been around for about 60 years basically
you're injecting into deep wells water
under high pressure with sand to crack
open rocks to release hydrocarbon
molecules like oil and natural gas
what other chemicals are used in the
fracking process well there are a
variety of chemicals they're used for
basically corrosion resistance to
prevent bacteria from fouling the
equipment and the pipes and so forth and
some of them are are hazardous you
wouldn't want to drink them they're
things like benzene for example or
formaldehyde critics charge that
fracking releases gases that then bubble
up and pollute water is that what's
going on so far there are no examples
where this has been found
no examples anywhere this ones that's
the good news the bad news is is that
when you dig these wells they need to
have casing piping in order to conduct
the molecules up the natural gas or the
oil and if you don't do it right then
what will happen is that the gas could
escape and get into people's drinking
water and this has happened but this is
what will happen even with conventional
wells it has nothing to do with the
technology of hydro fracturing or
fracking is everything to do with the
fact that somebody created it well
incompetently
talked a little bit about that process
by which gas got into people's water
wells and when they turn on their
faucets they could light it on fire is
that what's happening that has happened
in some cases for example famously and a
little
town called Dimock Pennsylvania we're an
energy company called Cabot energy had
dug about 60 wells in a nine square mile
area and they use fracking technology in
order to get the gas out of the ground
but that wasn't the problem the problem
was is the casings that is the lining of
the wells were defective and this was
determined by the Pennsylvania
Department of Environmental Protection
and because of these defective casings
natural gas escaped into people's well
water and that is a problem and the
companies now had to pay the citizens
whose wells have been harmed but four
million dollars for that a number of
anti-fracking people point to the case
of Sublette Wyoming where supposedly
that's what happened again it's not the
technology of fracking that seems to
have been the problem there the federal
agencies that looked into the matter
have concluded that the wells that were
contaminated were contaminated
essentially by trucks that brought in
the substances in this case benzene when
they were busy siphoning water out of
the wells I should also point out these
wells were not drinking water wells they
were industrial wells it's still bad
that they were contaminated but the
technology or a fracking did not cause
it itself but basically was mishandled
surface water why is it becoming so
controversial right now it moved into a
new area that is the East Coast
Pennsylvania New York Ohio and West
Virginia because we've discovered
something called the Marcellus Shale the
more populated area an area in rural
areas where people have not had to put
up with the production of oil and
natural gas they're just not used to it
so there was a kind of a NIMBY backlash
to it and natural gas is also relatively
clean fuel the Department of Energy's
National Energy Technology Laboratory
estimates that burning natural gas would
produce about half the amount of
greenhouse gases than burning coal does
so it really is perhaps a bridge fuel if
you will to a lower carbon energy future
the New York State Attorney General
recently filed a lawsuit claiming that
federal agencies that allow fracking
haven't really adequately studied the
issues or the cost benefits or the
particular harms of it is the New York
State Attorney General on to something
here I don't believe that he is actually
we've been doing a hundred thousand of
these wells a year for many many years
the technology's been around for 60
years basically the technology is
as far as we can tell what much more
study is really required what's the
great potential of fracking I mean can
we be doing what should we be doing more
of it and what's what's the potential
payoff versus the potential risks that
we've talked about the potential payoffs
are enormous to fracking basically the
natural gas supply for United States
will last a hundred years of current
usages we could move in the direction of
reducing greenhouse gases very cheaply
using this technology to to produce
electricity it's a great benefit indeed
another thing that's happening is the
technology is now being used just now
being adapted to oil production and it
is possible there are new estimates out
there using that technology we could
essentially produce three million new
barrels of oil a day by 2020 that's the
size of the production of Kuwait and
that would be all onshore would not be
in the Gulf and it would be a huge
benefit to the economy again in those
ways Ron Bailey I want to thank you for
talking to reason TV today about
fracking and its discontents for Reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]